[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà je m'appelle ina je ne suis pas
française
je suis pas né je n'ai pas grandi en
france et pourtant je parle
j'écris je réfléchis en français je suis
l'auteur de plusieurs publications en
langue française dans les librairies en
france
vous retrouverez dans la catégorie
auteurs francophones comme au premier
rang 2e livres sont parus
certains y ont vu un paradoxe on va
poser la question suivante mais vivant
au liban
qu est ce que tu écris en français
vois-tu n'écrirai pas en langue arabe la
langue maternelle on langue anglaise
si c'est la mondialisation que tu vises
cette question posée à posteriori elles
m'ont un peu sembler paradoxal à moi
parce que moi j'ai écrit dans mon flux
bien quand mon inspiration poule
je ne la demande pas elle vient en
français alors je me suis pas posé la
question suivante qu'est-ce qui commande
le choix du lord écriture et calcul
langue maternelle est ce qu une langue
étrangère aussi sont elles si clairement
définis elles feront taire la frontière
entre les deux est ainsi clairement
délimitée n'est-elle pas clos quelque
part pour essayer de creuser cette
énigme de trouver réponse à cette
question et pourquoi pas renverser ce
paradoxe
j'ai aidé creuser cet impensé et je me
suis posé la question de savoir quel
rapport entretient avec chaque land
pour cela je suis monté au moment de la
rencontre
alors faut dire qu'au moment de la
j'ai pas le grand mérite parce que je
suis tombé dans la marmite du
trilinguisme à la naissance
je suis né dans un pays où je suis né
dans un pays où le système scolaire est
ainsi fait c'est un système bilingue on
a on a accès à trois langues des classes
primaires et et après ou leurs
complémentaires la langue maternelle de
langue arabe et de langues étrangères
l'anglais et le français
d'accord mais je n'ai toujours pas
répondu à ma question pourquoi est ce
que j'écris en langue française la
langue maternelle ces langues des
parents de la maison et si je revenais à
la maison je lui dois vous avouer une
chose aussi ce que moi à la maison dès
mes premiers balbutiements
j'ai imprimé premier veau en 3 landes en
arabe en français ou en anglais
papa maman habite wah wah l'amour haye
et tais toi ma vie ok est ce qu'on a dit
ok n'ai pas peur mais celle râle ça va
aller donc et dire des mots pour dire je
t'aime des mots pour assurer aussi en
trois langues
pour rassurer parce que si je suis né il
faut l'avouer je suis né dans un pays en
guerre
mais rassurez-vous aussi quand la
naissance on est dans un pays en guerre
on pense que cela est normal on pense
que c'est normal d'étudier trois langues
sous les bombes
on pense que c'est normal il étudia la
lumière de la bougie parce que les
lectrices découpé et le courant est
rationnée on pense que c'est normal
d'apprendre sa grand mère sa grand-mère
en trois langues
s'il a une image qui me revient de cette
époque là c'est bien l'image d'une
grande table de la salle à manger et -6
un bout de la table vous en mets de voir
deux petites filles alors que dehors et
à la guerre et à l'autre bout de la
table on perd un avocat de l'enfance et
l'eau à la main en train de rédiger ses
réquisitoires et entre plaidoyers
à présenter au tribunal le jour où sera
ce tribunal sera ouvert un jour
d'accalmie c'est travailler à partir de
la maison ceux qui avaient d'insécurité
qui vais pas aller à à son bureau comme
moi ce jour là je pouvais pas aller à
l'école donc sur une même table de
personnes qui font leurs devoirs sur une
même table en plusieurs langues lui en
langue arabe est la langue officielle la
langue des lois mais aussi en langue
française parce que le liban est un pays
qui était sous mandat français et donc
les livres de jurisprudence doctrine
pouvait être en français et en arabe est
loi libanaise et ont été inspirées du
code napoléonien et des lois françaises
émoi face à lui en trois langues
est ce qu'il ya à retenir de cette image
là c'est qu'à l'intérieur de la maison
c'était le règne des mots alors que de
voir c'était le règne des armes des mois
en trois langues
alors que dehors peut-être des personnes
qui parlaient la même langue ne se
comprenaient pas des mots pour dire
l'absurdité de ce monde
l'absurdité dans laquelle des peuples
peuvent être plongée des mots pour
conjurer des fois l'absurdité de ce
monde et s'accrocher pour pouvoir des
mots qu'en dehors ce n'est pas les mots
qui font la loi
il faut dire que à la fin de mes études
après avoir fini mes études la petite
fille à cette époque là y'avait pas
encore les tablettes est pas non plus
non plus les télé par satellite avait
les livres des livres en trois langues
que l'on peut l'on m'a donné aussi mais
la petite fille a été faire une
bibliothèque en couleur il du tac en
rose et en verre il a semblé beaucoup
plus séduisante que d'autres et donc
elle est accro s'étaient vus potiron
c'était le clandestin le club 17
il y avait aussi martin bob et bobette
sidonie c'était un monde enchanté un
monde tout mignon qui me semblait
beaucoup plus beau que ce qu'avaient à
l'extérieur elle est bien sûr tonnerre
hier si y'avait bobby brown un peu
d'anglais et puis après avoir lu ses
livres
bon il a appris à la comtesse de ségur
mais à la télé qu'est ce qu'il y avait à
la télé y avait aussi chantal goya qui
se souvient de chantal casimir le
soulier qui vole la forêt enchantée et
le lapin qui tue un chasseur c'est sympa
un lapin qui tient chasseurs mais
rassurez vous je suis pas resté à
chantal
plus tard j'ai évolué l'adolescence
alors les lectures ont continué à
l'adolescence daguerre et déterminer les
périodes un peu d'insouciance
on recherche la liberté on a envie de
s'évader d'avoir de grandes idées
alors oui il rousseau et puis voltaire
et puis etc mais l'adolescent s'est
aussi les séries américaines c'est
beverly hills
c'est melrose place et friends c'est
tout le cinéma américain c'est tous les
chanteurs américains
l'adolescence est une période de
légèreté et d'insouciance dans les
bandes s'étaient tues le française des
dons monde enchanté l'anglais s'était
ajouté mme tonight
c'était un moment de divertissement et
d'insouciance et la langue arabe
je vous ai pas parlé la langue arabe et
pourtant elle était omniprésente la
langue maternelle
je ne ressens pas le besoin de justifier
c'est la maison la maison en feu nos
fêtes
c'est un peu c'était là dorothée
libanaise may à celle maquis qui raconte
la guerre avec des mots d'enfant et en
chansons patriotiques
c'est le jt de 20h qui égrenait les
morts les blessés c'est la langue des
politiciens hauts ni corrompus la langue
arabe
c'est la famille famille je ne t'ai pas
choisi pas unis je t'aime c'est aussi la
langue de tout l'amour que j'ai reçu
c'est toute la chaleur dont j'ai été
entourée mais une famille des fois on a
des fois l'image d'un enfant malade on
rêve un jour de voir en bonne santé et
famille d'être un enfant turbulent
on rêve de voir assagi un jour on
voudrait le plus faire de souci pour lui
alors la langue arabe cette famille mois
de la rave en français évidemment c'est
dans cette langue là que j'ai appris
arriver cette langue qui m'a protégé qui
m'a maxime à materner qui m'a donné un
regard plus coloré plus beau donner
envie de regarder et de sourire dans
l'avenir et dans cette langue là moi
j'ai décidé n'est pas décidé qu'il a
apprise à l'école je laissais de me
l'approprier et d'en faire une langue et
lui choisi d'en faire une deuxième
langue maternelle tout simplement
et qui a dit qu'on devait avoir qu'une
seule langue maternelle des fois on
rencontre des amis et ses amis on les
choisit il devient notre
même famille c'est pareil pour une
langue on a une première femme dans une
deuxième est donc cette langue là cette
francophonie que manger de la vie auteur
francophone de mes ordres cette
étiquette
quelle différence entre moi et un auteur
français qui écrit un livre en langue
française je regarde très serein sur
cette étiquette là aucun regard
discriminatoire parce que pour moi être
un auteur francophone c'est tout
simplement cela veut dire que je j'ai
appris à réfléchir en trois langues en
anglais en français en arabe
ma pensée structurée en trois langues
puis j'ai donc eu accès à trois cultures
et que ce sens qui s'est construit basé
sur trois cultures j'ai décidé sciemment
ou inconsciemment qu importe de mettre
des mots dessus en france est ma langue
maternelle
j'ai donc choisi ma deuxième parce qu'il
faut dire que cette langue s'ajoute à
mes deux autres langues
aucune culture les intérieurs à une
autre nom étiquette d'auteurs
francophones ce n'est pas
discriminatoire contraire pour moi c'est
une richesse parce que ma francophonie
et englobante d'un multilinguisme d'un
multiculturalisme
le français pour moi n'est par exemple
pas ennemis de l'anglais dans mon
imaginaire c'est une chose à laquelle ma
francophonie s'opposent ce serait
peut-être usage d'une langue instruments
véhiculaire d'une langue de la
mondialisation qui serait le globish
english ce cet anglais l'aéroport oui
parce que pour moi il lança un max et
l'accès à d'autres cultures c'est
l'accès à d'autres langues à notre
langue maternelle
et donc quand on apprend juste les
rudiments d'une land on reste un stade
superficiel on ne connaît pas vraiment
l'autre nous restons les étrangers l'un
à l'autre si je ne connais pas ta langue
maternelle tu connais pas la mienne
nous allons parler en anglais ensemble
juste pour se comprendre avec des
rudiments ne pas vraiment se connaître
on va toujours savoir que nous sommes
des étrangers alors moi pour moi la
langue n'est pas qu'un instrument de
communication
la langue c'est une arme la plus belle
que l'on est inventé
pour aplatir des frontières pour
s'approprier des cultures pour habiter
des territoires pour habiter son monde
il s'en tire de moins en moins étrangers
l'un à l'autre voilà donc l'auteur
francophone que je suis et la
francophonie pour moi ça veut dire à
multilinguisme
parce quand on connaît beaucoup de
langues banques se sent de moins en
moins étrangers l'un à l'autre on sent
tout simplement qu'on est puissant
on peut aller partout dans le monde et
se sentir chez soi a priori parce qu'on
se sent pas étranger c'est un peu une
métaphore et pense à une métaphore celle
de d'hommes et de femmes augmente et
quant aux aptitudes cognitives sont
amplifiées et cela par la connaissance
d'autres cultures par la compréhension
d'autres personnes alors on peut dire
qu'on se sent plus puissant plus fort
dans ce monde et c'est ça pour moi que
cela inspire le fait apprendre de
nouvelles langues
[Musique]
donc voilà je voulais vous dire que pour
moi le multilinguisme
je pense que ça fait de nous des hommes
et des femmes augmenter et si j'ai un
regret à ce stade là c'est de n'être que
trilingue
j'aimerais beaucoup apprendre d'autres
langues devenir polyglotte pour pouvoir
aller dans des pays dont je ne mettrai
pas la langue et me sentir chez moi
aussi pour mieux comprendre les autres
parce que communiquer à travers une
langue instruments c'est vrai que ça
permet bonne communication mais ça
n'assure pas une bonne
intercompréhension il faut admettre que
la communication guette au bout du fil
alors pour moi les langues c'est une
façon de sentir puissant de sentir fort
le centre riche
le multi le multilinguisme m'a formé
mais trois langues se sont agrégées dans
mon cerveau elles ont fait celle que je
suis aujourd'hui celle qui sent plus
libre plus forte d'habiter dans ce monde
d'aller devenir de ne pas me sentir
étrangères les langues c'est une façon
pour moi de jouer
de mélanger les casses de mélanger les
lignes et de me sentir bien libre de
rêver dans une langue d'écrire dans
l'une des mes dans une troisième d'un
succès dans une quatrième est tout
naturellement de venir devant vous et de
faire cet automne en français évidemment
et naturellement je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]